una séptima audiencia para brittney
griner ante el tribunal de james y cerca
de moscú los últimos debates están
previstos para el jueves y el veredicto
final debería llegar en los próximos
días el juicio tomó una nueva dimensión
desde que moscú y washington empezaron
sus conversaciones sobre un posible
canje de prisioneros que incluye la
deportista sexto focos ella sigue
concentrada y todavía está nerviosa y
sabe que el final está cerca y por
supuesto se enteró de las noticias así
que espera que en algún momento pueda
volver a casa y nosotros también lo
esperaba mejor
concretamente el secretario de estado
estadounidense anthony blinken propuso
al ministro de exteriores ruso serguéi
lávrov una oferta para lograr la
liberación de la basquetbolista y el
veterano paul wiland que sería a cambio
de entregar al traficante víctor boots
un ruso que fue declarado culpable de
tráfico de armas y que cumple una
condena de 25 años de prisión en eeuu
aunque rusia critica la manera en que
washington maneja la comunicación sobre
este y
seguimos pensando que cualquier
intercambio de información sobre este
tema debe hacerse con discreción la
diplomacia megafón ame el intercambio
público de opiniones no logrará
resultados
weiner fue detenida en un aeropuerto de
moscú en febrero con un líquido de
vaporizador a base de cannabis la
deportista se declaró culpable de
contrabando de drogas aunque ha dicho
repetidamente que no tenía la intención
de llevar a rusia un producto prohibido
se enfrenta a 10 años de prisión en lo
que eeuu considera como un caso político
que moscú sa como una medida de presión